hey everybody I'm here with Tony rich
executive director of the st. Louis
Chess Club men's classic Center and from
what I've heard also the best chess
player out of the employees Tony can you
confirm that well my ratings just over
two thousand so I'm an expert level
player that might be true actually right
now although of course having guys like
you on staff at the moment certainly
lowers my my chances but out of the
regular employees are still would you
say the King I hope so yeah well I have
to see if they agree but yeah let's say
yes so as a chess fan and a member of
the club how's the sink built cup
running so far this year
you know the sink filled cups been a
blast it always is for us in particular
this year it's been nice because we've
had so many memorable moments from
segments like chess a - you know
obviously the players themselves being
here in town you know these are one of
the few events that we're able to host
and really spotlight st. Louis and
really kind of bring it to the forefront
not just for the chess world but for
everybody else too so it's a great time
for all of us do you think Wesley so is
gonna close out the tournament I do I do
you know it's funny during the opening
ceremony one of the questions asked was
who do you think will win or who do you
think is your biggest rival in the event
and nobody picked Wesley so I'm kind of
happy to see him up there leading the
tournament now and he seems comfortable
and confident obviously like I said 1/2
point lead right now so right that's
right so certainly a good time for
American chess with these three top 10
players it looks like the strongest of
Olympia team ever some people may not
know that you're also a fidei arbiter
since they're doing a bunch of things I
wanted to ask you what is the hardest
forfeit you've ever handed out you know
I may hold the infamous record of
forfeiting some of the highest rated
players including two former world
champions and my boss those of you that
tuned in and saw ultimate moves the the
Blitz event or ultimate bleach showdown
you'll know that I did forfeit Rex and
his teammates which included Veselin
Topalov former world champion and Gary
Kasparov the luminary legendary former
world champion as well so I think I may
have forfeited more strong chess players
than anybody else
that's a pretty that's pretty remarkable
right so the Chess Club hosts top events
like this but also does a lot of other
things would you be able to elaborate on
some of the other exciting projects the
club is up to right now
sure so our three main program areas are
the major events like these the club
itself where we host classes and
lectures and tournaments for everyone
from beginners through advanced players
and then really our bread and butter and
where we spend a lot of effort is our
scholastic chess program in fact I just
got done with a meeting with some of our
scholastic guys we have over 120 schools
signed up for this fall semester already
and more and more are coming in every
day so it's great seeing these young
chess players learn the game of chess in
their school and then come down to the
club and enjoy the club environment and
then finally to be able to see them here
at a sing field Cup and chasing behind
these great players and trying to get
autographs it's wonderful yeah I had a
pretty fun time myself I taught three of
the camps here in st. Louis the summer
and seems like the numbers are growing
every time I come by is there a chance
you could maybe leak some information to
the chassez audience about any of the
any anything this fall that the club
might be up to I know the club sometimes
runs tournaments is that possible any
weeks on the show yeah absolutely so
this fall we will indeed host a match
it'll be right around the middle of
November it will feature Fabiano car you
wanna Hikaru Nakamura and two other
players yet-to-be-named some combination
of rapid classical blitz give all of
these players a chance to shine yet
again here in st. Louis and lastly the
special question you're on a second date
and your date asks you to bring a friend
because they'd like to bring a friend as
well which of the ten players would you
take as a wingman do I have to bring one
of the players or can I choose a
commentator
I'd like a player preferably well if I
had to pick a player I would say Levon
Aronian
just so smoothly easygoing disarming
he's an excellent guy but if I did have
to pick a commentator I'd probably have
to say my buddy Eric Hanson
that's amazing well there you have it we
got special news about a match coming up
we've got new t-shirts out with my face
on it everything's going well over here
back to the studio for some more chess
analysis
oh yeah it was